dude yeah just imagine you wake up after
like 3000 years you're like all right I
got a big dick and then everybody's like
dude everything's the same nobody likes
big dicks anymore it's just all small
dicks I don't think it'll ever happen
everything that's the only difference in
society
the [ __ ] Ultima Nissan looks exactly
the same just people don't like big
dicks
[Music]
all right so there is this company in
Arizona it's a cryonics facility you
know what they do like freeze people not
cryotherapy or like Advanced cryogenic
to keep them for [ __ ] 100 years just
in case some [ __ ] gets Advanced would
you pay 200k to preserve your body no
[ __ ] no is there a guarantee that my
body's gonna work afterwards yeah would
you survive no but there is a guarantee
that your body will still be intact by
the time science catches up to that idea
oh hell no dude I don't trust it you
don't want to wake up in year three
thousand nah I kind of like I'm not
suicidal but I kind of want to die at
some point you know what I mean like
it's like I don't want to be I was just
talking about this yesterday yeah you
know what I meant hey do you need a
friend he Master suicidal though he said
that already no it's just like imagine
like you want to die you know that
sounds so everyone wants that but it
sounds horrible torture I would want to
live
forever if I could be this this healthy
at some point like where I'm at right
now but to be
95 and like feel 95 now I'm out bro I
ain't doing that [ __ ] like I don't I
never want what's the oldest you think
you would be my grandpa lived in 95 and
but he was like bedridden for like five
ten years I don't want that [ __ ] to
happen I I think I'll be happy going out
to like 75 like but I want to be out
heart attack I feel like I can handle
bedridden nowadays it's got so many
streaming services I feel like it sucks
for people back in the day they just had
the life dude you'd blow your brains out
I don't think I would want someone else
to wipe my ass yeah yeah like [ __ ] in a
[ __ ] diaper and stuff speak for
yourself you know something about that
sound kind of tired what if it's a robot
by then interesting yeah or maybe if
it's a robot wiping my ass that'd be
kind of interesting
yeah it'd be kind of cool but I was
reading a book called being mortal by
Atul gawande it's a book about aging
it's just like it seems so terrible to
be [ __ ]
dependent on someone else yeah yeah are
we all like team pull the plug hell yeah
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah take me now man
that's gotta be the scariest thing is
being on life support and you're
sentient and you want to die and your
family just hold it on yes that's half
of it it's like people are like beholden
to other people's wishes I don't want
that [ __ ] to happen at all because like
you guys have experienced sleep
paralysis before right yeah yeah that's
the worst [ __ ] but now imagine that for
three years straight put a pillow over
my face shoot me in the [ __ ] we're
listening to your family grieving about
finances to [ __ ] keep you alive and
[ __ ] yeah I don't want that [ __ ] hearing
the doctor give the bills kill them
we in the will
he's moving his hand
oh man he's just
the cryogenic thing too like imagine 200
000 years in advance or whatever like
how different like you wouldn't even the
world wouldn't even make sense dude like
none of your friends will be around you
would just be like what you know people
are like orbs now or some [ __ ] it's like
just like it's we wouldn't even be able
to Fathom how crazy the world is like or
or even if it's like almost regular it's
like maybe they could bring back your
body to life because your body's intact
but what about your mind and your soul
you know what I mean I actually can't
bring your spirit that's lame that's
like he's gonna all sentimental that's
why they put crystals can they bring you
back with a bigger dick
speak their language if they can
regenerate at that point then I'm sure
they can have bigger dick technology
yeah but they're like not for that
though and I'll be like oh but what if
that's not in Style by then yeah yeah
yeah yeah ball Dixon leave me in baby
dude yeah just imagine you wake up after
like 3000 years you're like all right I
got a big dick and then everybody's like
dude everything's the same nobody likes
big dicks anymore it's just all small
dicks I don't think it'll ever happen
everything that's the only difference in
society no no it's everything's the same
though like you wake up and everything
is the same the [ __ ] Ultima Nissan
looks exactly the same just people don't
like big dicks yeah no like you wake up
it's like people are still going get
into war or whatever whatever and it's
like literally the same thing but like
more LED lights the Tesla cyber truck is
still not out yet and [ __ ] but like big
dicks are like out of style
what problems did you guys solve nothing
no that's I legit think that's what
that's what would happen if you were to
wake up like a thousand years in the
future it just probably wouldn't be that
different you don't think so no I don't
think so it's gonna be crazy A Thousand
Years look at 1970s technology look at
now yeah but then once you look at the
Flash five years isn't it that you can't
even go back in time more than I think
200 years or something before you're
unable to understand in the English
language huh that sounds like something
like that let's talk about it right yeah
like because the way people talk back
then like it changes so much that you go
back in time and you're like what year
is it they'll just be like
well your age and like the 1940s with
all the stuff you know now you oh people
your age dude they're being [ __ ]
working they would be like in a mind
yeah people said Sport and [ __ ] you know
sport lad they'll call me I'd be like
thine is make it my sack warm yeah and
I'll be like what are you saying I'm
horny it's like kind of what I'm saying
right yeah and you wake up and then the
main language in the whole entire world
is just Chinese oh [ __ ] because they
took over that I'd be really [ __ ] yeah
that'd be screwed but that's why little
dicks are in
what's up I think I would be frozen I
think it'd be cool yeah just why not die
anyway what age because you want it like
to be young enough that's true you have
to cut off at an earlier Point all that
means it's like hey you're getting old
you better now well you're sentient huh
probably like
60s I think you want to get Frozen at
60. yeah I think so yeah I think it'd be
good that's a good age how about this
you can not only freeze your body but
you can just do your brain for 80k
yeah the bootleg version yeah give me
the discount for you not just my brain
like put you in a cyborg body in the
future possibly I'll do that one and
even if they had the technology what is
my guarantee that this company is going
to stay in business for that long oh
that's another thing GoFundMe yeah
I know it's true you're about to launch
a new business right now listen guys I
got this idea okay that's a pretty big
give me twenty thousand dollars I'll
freeze you I promise for now I'll wake
you up we gotta get in the cryo game
dude you know what you know I feel like
this really is it's just a [ __ ] organ
harvesting front yeah for sure but don't
they have celebrities that actually do
this [ __ ] yeah there's 1400 people that
are doing this right now yeah they're
all they're already signed up Oh I
thought they were frozen already I was
like damn they're already crazy yeah you
already got ice trays they're all doing
this how is this legal some people are
already Frozen for sure maybe not
necessarily through this company but the
idea of cryo freezing and [ __ ] like that
to preserve your body it's already
happened for like a couple decades or
something well you're talking about your
[ __ ] people on Mount Everest yeah
people have been Pros yeah people have
been frozen ones yeah look at that no
way there's Frozen people right now for
sure but it's also a trailer how does
that even happen like legal like
legality wise like how is that even I
don't know yeah I don't know you just
signed a paper well in this one living
people who plan that's plan to be prior
preserved I don't know if anyone's
Frozen right and especially if you got
the first gen cryotech that's some
garbage yeah you need you need the the
third evolution you're just with ice
cubes in the freezer like it says as of
2014 about 250 corpses have been
cryogenically preserved in the U.S and
around 1500 people have signed up okay
that's uh that's already dead so let's
see yeah I think this is the same deal
like it's it's more you're saying freeze
when you're already a lot who wants to
[ __ ] go in to freeze before they die
Encino Man are they already dying and
then freezing themselves but this isn't
like this isn't like hey you die here so
this one is mainly for people with a
terminal disease that are going anywhere
now I feel like a dick so they wanna
yeah man [ __ ] those dead people yeah
yeah yeah you're dying you're basically
dead exactly like a jerk there's no cure
does this mean they wake up in like a
thousand years and then they just die
then yeah okay how about this probably
there's a girl who had brain cancer she
she's from Thailand she's the youngest
person to be crowd preserved at the age
of two whoa whoa okay so they're hoping
that they'll get a cure for hurricane
sir in the future I'm looking for her
I don't know about the rest of them but
then but what if she hates oil though oh
yeah yeah oh yo then what bro damn bro
that's a problem
do her parents have to be cryo preserved
too is she just gonna wake up in the
future with no parents
[Music]
yeah I mean she just she said oh [ __ ]
the brain tumor I never knew existed is
gone however I am an orphan yes yeah and
you got to navigate this whole [ __ ]
world yeah and I'm a celebrity that I
didn't ask to be because I was the first
to come back out of that and also your
two so you're not even thinking that
coherently you're still like [ __ ] in
your pants yeah you're too you're just
two you just wake up and you're like
[ __ ] my pants and then eventually figure
out you don't have parents you're making
it too real man but then they also don't
yet have the technology to thaw a human
that was frozen and they're totally fine
right oh man
there's a lot of holes yeah it's hard
enough trying to thaw chicken without
like poisoning yourself bro how are you
gonna thaw out a [ __ ] human
make sure they wake up like all good
under running water constantly you can't
even do the Blackout Challenge and wake
up all good oh man yeah I don't know man
it seems like a lot of medical
professionals do not believe in this
[ __ ] they're just like it's a scam is
this the same category as crystals
they just write in journals all day yeah
they've never Frozen anybody they don't
[ __ ] unless OJ the gynecologist what
he thinks about it his medical [ __ ]
medical opinions Dr juice
Dr juice that's funny
[Music]
[Music]
foreign